foreign
ARD at Sky News back with another extra
episode of The Daily because we can now
use the name of the BBC presenter
accused of paying a teenager thousands
of pounds for explicit photos
it's Hugh Edwards the corporation's most
senior news presenter
Jake Canter is back with me
investigations editor at deadline but
also he was media editor at the Times
a date we can now say it's Hugh Edwards
because of a statement from his wife
Vicki Flynn let's go over the details of
it yeah that's right I mean it feels
like
the tone of this story is going to
change significantly as a result of this
statement
um as I've been reporting on this for
the last five days it has always been at
the back of my mind that Hugh Edwards
has spoken about his mental health
struggles in the past
and I just felt that it was going to be
inevitable that that would be an issue a
play here and it's clear from Vicki
Flynn's statement that the recent days
have been very traumatic for them as a
family
and it's taken its toll on Hugh Edwards
as an individual to the point where he's
been receiving inpatient Care at a
hospital
um
he himself has not yet commented and
Vicki Flynn said that he won't do so
until
he is able to do so which suggests that
he won't be commenting until he's made
some sort of recovery
um when you were in the statement she
says that he's already been treated for
depression before I remember in his
Instagram there were a number of posts
about mental health and depression so
this is someone who has serious mental
health issues yeah he's spoken about it
openly a number of times in the past uh
both through his own social media
channels and through interviews and
um it is something he is an advocate for
he talks about it openly because he
wants to
help others talk about it and
um it feels like the scrutiny that he's
been under it was just
uh going to be you know it always felt
like that that could be problematic
potentially for him individually and for
the family and
uh what we might see I think as I say is
a change in the tone of the coverage
potentially
um and it's clear that the BBC the BBC
has been sort of signaling some of this
in its statements in recent days they've
been talking about duty of care they've
been talking about moving forward
carefully
um so there's been hints at some of this
uh in the BBC's language and
um it's clear that they the BBC itself
is going to have to move forward very
carefully when it comes to picking up
the investigation uh and making sure
that it you know has a responsibility to
both Hugh Edwards and his family and to
those who have made allegations against
him and that's not necessarily an easy
Balancing Act and in that statement his
wife goes on to say he is now having
hospital care and will be there for the
foreseeable
yeah I mean look
that sounds like uh it could be
an indefinite period of time I mean I
don't really want to speculate about his
own State
and you know
how significant uh his mental health
issues are at the moment
um but it sounds like the fact that
he has not been able to respond
personally suggests that you know as I
say it's going it's a very difficult
moment for them as a family
however that statement does go on to say
that he does intend to respond
to these stories that have been
published
yes and I don't think that's surprising
um you know Hugh Edwards
is known to his colleagues as
um someone who is prepared to stand up
for what he believes in
uh he uh is known as someone who will
defend his track record and his
character
um
people talk about him uh being you know
very proud of his own achievements and I
think when the time is right we will see
some of those
characteristics coming out in his
response to these allegations
and then the final part of the statement
in which his wife asks for privacy
yeah well look uh
we're in this situation where
there has been privacy in the fact that
he hasn't been named
um and yet equally there has been this
wild speculation online and
unfortunately Hugh Edwards has become
the subject of that wild speculation in
recent days
um hopefully in a sort of strange way
naming him will sort of release some of
that pressure the the speculation uh
will die down and
um potentially hopefully
the family will be given the respect of
their privacy and the BBC can get on
with its work investigating this matter
so Jake I think it's it's probably worth
taking people back over Hugh Edwards BBC
career he's obviously one of their
highest paid stars and he has anchored
key moments in history for them
so Hugh Edwards is I would say
unquestionably at the peak of his powers
um he is the BBC's highest paid and
highest profile news anchor and he has
been trusted with some of the biggest
moments in the BBC's history he was the
man who delivered the news
of the Queen's death to the nation that
is arguably the biggest story in
Generations in the UK and then having
done that went on to Anchor coverage of
the funeral which has won a bafta this
year
and more recently uh he obviously was
also in the presenters chair for the
coronation of King Charles III
before his wife's statement came out
we'd heard that the Met police
um say that there was no evidence of of
a crime from where from what it had seen
so just just before his wife's statement
we'd heard the Met police say that there
was no evidence of a crime from what it
had seen
yeah I mean look I think
clearly that will come as some relief to
Hugh Edwards in the family it moves the
focus of this story from one of
allegations of a potentially criminal
nature
uh to uh allegations that are less
serious and
um
having said that it does not believe
that this requires further investigation
the Met police has handed the Baton back
to the BBC and the BBC will now restart
its own investigation into this matter
and I think as I said earlier I think
this is a tricky balancing act for the
BBC they'll have to clearly have a duty
of care to Hugh Edwards and his family
but also they have a Duty Care to the
individuals who've made the allegations
and it will have to walk that tightrope
over the coming weeks and months
hmm
so he's been named but
should the last few days have been
different
I think we probably need a bit more time
to consider what's taken place I think
there are clearly some questions about
the mechanics and application of
defamation and privacy laws in the UK
they have protected Hugh Edwards to a
point right
um the media have not named him and his
identity has been you know partially
uh partially protected as a result of
that what the laws have not been able to
tackle is in quite the same way is the
Wild and defamatory speculation on
social media and uh that speculation has
impacted both Hugh Edwards but also
uh some of his very high profile
colleagues including Jeremy Vine Nikki
Campbell Gary lineker all of whom have
faced baseless totally baseless
allegations over the last few days and
that suggests that while it has provided
some protection to Hugh Edwards it has
actually put others in danger
and that is something that we should
consider I think going forward so we had
the sun story about the pictures and the
subsequent claims about his conduct
online and on dating apps but without
definitive evidence of criminality
some were starting weren't they to
question what the story was here
yeah and I think we'll probably see more
reflection on that over over the coming
days actually I think we'll probably
start to see more questions about the
sun's own reporting and uh why it has
not been clearer about the evidence that
it has
um and clearer about the seriousness of
the evidence that it has
um it allowed a situation in which
other Publications
determined that the allegations that
were made by the family of the
individual concerned may be criminal in
nature and of course we now know the
police do not agree with that potential
assessment
um so it's clear that the sun
will probably come under some scrutiny
over the coming days
his family have asked for privacy so in
terms of the media what are the rules
and the expectations going forward now
I would hope that
um my colleagues in the press and you
guys at Sky News and I'm sure others uh
respect Hugh Edwards and his family's
privacy uh it's clear that they're going
through a moment of real and genuine
trauma
um but also the BBC has to carry out a
process of Investigation to determine
whether although the allegations may not
be criminal in nature whether they
actually
um raise uh concerns and questions about
his his professional conduct and that's
a that's a very different matter and the
BBC will have to come to its own
determination on that because in that
assuming you really get a sense of just
how how damaging this has been to
not only Hugh Edwards but his family as
well yeah I mean clearly it's been
I mean they've been in an uh at the at
the eye of the most extraordinary media
storm over the past five days I mean
it's hard to imagine how these events
could have played out in a more public
way and I think it's also important to
remember that there's another family in
trauma as well and that is the family
who
um uh made the allegations originally
the original allegations in the sun
about uh hughead was his condos and
we've got two families in trauma and I
think we should be cognizant of that and
when I say we I mean the prayer should
be cognizant of that uh in our future
coverage
let's talk talk about his career and his
position the most senior news anchor
what does it tell us
this storm that has been
um
carrying on for the last couple of days
what does it tell us about the
expectation of someone who is paid so
much of the license fee are they held to
a different account by the public
because he is a BBC star or was it
because he was essentially a trusted
news source for Millions
people felt that they knew him you know
Hugh Edwards is such a household name
yeah I think all of those things are
true
um I'm sure audiences uh will be really
shocked
um I'm sure Hugh Edwards is uh you know
he's he's an incredibly highly regarded
incredibly skilled broadcaster and uh he
is not in the position that he is in for
no good reason he is you know he is a
fixture in living rooms up and down the
country and I'm sure has many many fans
who admire his his professionalism and
his coverage and I'm I'm sure this will
be a difficult moment for those people
who who like the work that he does uh he
you know he is in many senses the the
BBC's face he is the man that you
associate with the the really key
moments in its trusted news coverage
whether it be uh you know those key
Royal events or indeed general elections
and yeah as result of that he is higher
he has held to incredibly high standards
but also I think it talks to a sort of a
a more General cultural shift I think uh
big personality is like Hugh Edwards and
indeed as we saw with Philip Schofield
they have they have responsibilities and
one of those responsibilities is to uh
you know be careful and consider it with
the power that they have
um and I'm not cast any aspersions on
Hugh webwards uh because we don't have
the full facts but if it is found that
he has abused his power and taken
advantage of
um young people
then the BBC will have to make uh some
decisions about whether he continues uh
you know on in quite the same way in
their coverage
um and also of course
you've got the element of the BBC being
in a position that it is it is in
receipt of you know billions of pounds
worth of public money and therefore it
holds a sort of special status in our
media landscape and is held to higher
standards as a result of that
that's Jake Cantor investigations editor
at deadline but he was also media editor
at the Times
this episode was produced by Emery
Woodhouse and the editor was Paul
stanworth